first there was the new xbox experience  in November now Microsoft is rolling out  another big system update for the Xbox  one and this time the focus is on social  features the update is available now for  anyone in the Xbox preview program and  the public release date is targeted for  februari with it comes a new gamerscore  leaderboard which will show how your  score ranks against your friends and  lets you see who earned the most over  the last 30 days you'll be able to  rearrange your pins on the homepage and  even launch some of them while you're  offline the update also includes  improvements to friends list suggestions  which broadcasts and the avatars store  it's not quite as hefty as the new xbox  experience but this update is still  bringing a lot of changes if Microsoft  decides to tweak even more you'll hear  about it from GameSpot and if you're  looking for the best site for Xbox one  news and reviews you're already in the  right place